hey buddy move to the people okay thank
you so this is based on work with Mach
bomb that is like very uncooperative
rush to get this table ready okay so the
outline of the talk is I'm going to tell
you about some of the sensitivity is the
timer might have led you to believe and
I'm particularly going to tell you about
some new algorithms that use the smooth
sensitivity framework but before I get
to that I'm going to sort of set the
scene a little bit by talking about a
motivating example applications with
sensitivity which is gonna be Gaussian
estimation which is very similar to what
the fish talked about on Monday or
Tuesday and a particular I'm gonna look
at the trimmed mean as today I'm going
to apply smooth sensitivity to the
problem of gasps you mean estimation via
this trimming mega and then I'll wrap up
in
and the overall moral of this talk is
that we're trying to get a little bit
more mileage out of the smooth sensitive
framework which is this really great
idea that I think under appreciate it
all right so let me start with sort of a
motivating problem which is the
estimation of the mean of a Gaussian so
you have data that's iid samples from
some Gaussian with unknown mean and your
goal is to figure out what that mean is
is accurately as possible and you know
let's just say some some bounds on where
that mean lies and also you know where
you know this the variance just for
simplicity that's not really necessary
just for the talk it's easier to know
and the constraint that makes this
difficult is that you must satisfy
differential privacy of some flavor now
I think there's a really important
problem because it's such a basic
problems it's really something we should
have solved you know right at the
beginning and that's why I think it's
important to study it just one one note
is that the distributional assumption is
only there to for utility the
differential privacy something is still
hold in the worst case for any input
okay so let me just sort of preview what
the with the result that we'll get at
the end is so assume that the number of
sample is sufficiently large then there
is gonna be a differentially private
algorithm that takes in samples from a
Gaussian and now puts an estimate of the
mean which has mean squared error this
so the first term is sort of the non
private optimal mean squared error so
that's exactly what we want and then you
get this additional term which is the
cost of privacy and you'll see that it's
not - not too large and in particular
since this is a over N squared for large
and there should be a lower order term
you should be getting basically the
right non private variance plus a low
order term which is kind of exactly what
we want now this bound basically matches
the previous work by vishesha this
allele that was talked about on Monday
they of course looked at confidence
intervals rather than mean squared error
but these are sort of roughly the same
so one thing to note is that this is not
this works fine if you have an unknown
Sigma I just get some extra terms and
it's also not specific to Gaussian data
so we apply this to a lot of different
distributions
okay so how do we do Gaussian mean
estimation on privately that's a pretty
standard thing you have your your data
and your non-private estimator is just
the empirical mean the average of the
the samples given this is unbiased so an
expectation gets see exactly what you
want and it has minimal variance so that
means that matches the Cramer a lore
about so the problem was trying to just
adapt this to the private setting is it
is infinite sensitivity right if you
take one of these samples off to
infinity then the entire estimate will
go off to infinity so we just can't add
noise and so the chef talked about this
in more detail but the one one
suggestion is truncation so you first
obtain some crude estimate of the mean
just just within a couple of standard
deviations then you truncate the data to
some interval and now you have finite
sensitivity and then you can add noise
to that
okay so I'll tell you about our approach
which just use the trimmed mean so what
does the trim mean so the the intuition
is to basically do a plier removal so
you take the and logis observations
throw them away throw away the bottom
and observations and just repose the
meaning of what's left over so a little
bit more mathematically it's a function
takes an ensemble that puts a single one
what you do is you sort the samples so
you get X 1 through X and in sorted
order and then you output the average of
the samples from M to n minus n plus 1
to n minus m and you average that
because you removed 2 to M of them
scaling so it's a fairly simple
operation but the nice thing is that now
the single point is not going to throw
things off too much and now my intuition
is that this interpolate between the
mean which corresponds to City n equals
0 and the median which corresponds to
saving m to be as large as possible what
that means
and this is unbiased which is nice so we
have a symmetric distribution you throw
something on the top you throw something
on the bottom as long as you threw off
the same amount it's not gonna affect
expectation and also turns out it
doesn't increase the variance too much
so basically you get the the variance
that you would get with the mean times
one plus some sort of lower order term
if you think that M is being much
smaller than Hannah both of these are
just corollary is it being a symmetric
distribution
okay so just to like make things a
little more concrete here's a here's a
graph of how the variance all changes
with M so if you have M equals 0 that
means you're just getting the the mean
and that's gonna have variance 1 over N
if you're looking at data from a
standard Gaussian as you do more and
more trimming the the variance goes up
until it reaches PI over 2 n which is
the variance of the median s and
topically so why am i showing you this
picture so I can show you the next
picture so I want to emphasize that this
is not trimming is sometimes a good
thing you might even do this even if
you're not concerned about privacy it
just for me can actually reduce variance
if the data is heavy tailed and one
example of a heavy tail distribution is
little pasta distribution which now we
don't usually think of this as being
heavy tailed but relative to the
Gaussian it's a little bit heavy tailed
and if you plot the same picture you'll
see that trimming actually reduces
variance it's very nice I think that
sort of tells us that we're on the right
track with this drawing yes in that case
even the median is the efficient
estimator for the right so the for the
loss the median is
but you know this also applies if you
have say a mixture of a Gaussian with
variance one and what a difference at
the settings you can actually winning
from
so if you have a symmetric distributions
general
so you could go back to the blast
pictures this it's going some either
going back up which contradicts four
times not to it so John is saying that
median is the best is it that for any
finite and you want to be a little bit
trimming what as a question means see
like asymptotically signals infinity
this was a cool okay so let's look at
the sensitivity of the true mean so
we'll assume that there's some kind of
bound on the data this can be a very
very loose
and this means we'll have you know
finite global sensitivity but it'll
still be quite large but what's smaller
is the local sensitivity so if instead
of looking at all neighboring databases
I just looked at databases that neighbor
my current database the one that I have
realized the sensitivity is much smaller
so basically the worst thing you could
do is either take the smallest thing
here and move it up to n minus n plus
one or vice versa you could take the
largest thing that's left here and move
it down to the smallest one of those are
the two terms and the max local
sensitivity
okay great so that is my segue into a
smooth sensitivity did you have a
question
okay so the idea of smooth sensitivity
is it was really nice so basically right
at the beginning of the literature of
differential privacy we learned that
adding noise proportional to the global
stability of a function provides the
friendship privacy but we really like to
be able to add noise is proportional to
something smaller like the local
sensitivity it's often that is is a lot
smaller now the problem with just doing
this is that this local sensitivity
itself may be high sensitivity so the
magnitude of the noise you're adding
could compromise privacy so for example
these two distributions have exactly the
same mean but totally different
variances and you know you can probably
tell these two apart you get a socket
from out here it's much more likely
going to blue them from the and the
solution is this smooth sensitivity
which is a really really beautiful idea
and this the point of this talk is to
say to reexamine this idea and see if we
can get more mileage out of it okay so
what's the what's the approach so let's
say we have some function f that's the
function we're interested in and we also
the second function G and we have the
fact that G is sort of a upper bound on
the local sensitivity of F so for all
neighboring databases f and f of X prime
can differ by most G but also we have
some multiplicative guarantee on the
sensitivity of G so on neighboring
databases you can G can only change by
multiplicative factor and then we're
going to just say that this is a G as a
t smooth upper bound on the local
sensitivity of there so suppose we have
one of these things in this one it's a
bit stronger than just local sensitivity
we have this then we can use the
following outdoor you take the function
f that we want we add some noise but now
we scale this noise according to G but
obviously the question is what noise
distribution Z can we use to make this
private and the key issue is that in
order to satisfy differential products
we need not just that an additive shift
remains indistinguishable but also that
a multiplicative shift distortion and
multiplicative discussion
just just a picture you know we have
this blue which has an additive
distortion over to the red and also a
multiplicative distortion to the green
or the French I need to make sure that
all these are going to be
indistinguishable in the sense of
differential privacy
okay so there's there's no unique
solution to right distribution for this
it really depends on various things so
I'll tell you what the the distributions
in the original paper so the first one
is the Cauchy distribution which is
density proportional 1 over 1 plus x
squared and you can sample this by just
looking at the ratio of two independent
standard gaussians and this provides
pure differential privacy but the
problem is that it has infinite variance
and even the mean is not defined
integral now you can look at a more
general distribution where you have a
higher power on X and this is gonna
still provide you crude of pure
differential privacy but with somewhat
worse parameters gamma but now you have
have your moments up to gamma minus 1 so
you have a couple of moments but not all
the moments will exist so and then
taking necessary if you have a
distribution for a purity people yes
don't the person three bullet points and
contradict each other it says provide
pure epsilon DV but then it's not so it
is necessary for a distribution
satisfying pure DP to not have all oh I
guess that is the logical implication
there you go so confused
and also they sure that you can use
Laplace choice or Gaussian noise but
then you have to move to epsilon Delta
approximate differential price which
means you're going to have to pick some
Delta and they also gonna have to pay
some sort of law one of the Delta yes
that's exactly what the next slide okay
so I'm going to tell you some some new
distributions so the first one I'm not
really new it's just a slight variation
on the one that we had on the previous
slide so just like inverse polynomial
thing has it has a name if you scale it
like this it's the student's
t-distribution the sign that people
study all the time as a nice way of
sampling it if you take the ratio of the
standard Gaussian with a chi square root
of a chi squared distribution that's
providing qgp also certain number of
moments exist I thought that's a nice
observation that this is a name but let
me tell you the first new distribution
which I call the Laplace log normal
distribution so basically what you do is
you take a standard Laplace that's Rx
and then you multiply it by a log normal
distribution so what normal is e to the
normal multiply these two together
and you need a distribution that's going
to satisfy concentrated DP
which is nice and also has all of its
moments all of the moments exist so it's
a much better behaved distribution
although again it's a different
definition of privacy so it turns out
you can actually do another variant of
this which is the what I call the
uniform log normal so instead of X
keying a little box random variable now
it's just uniform on minus 1 1 this also
has the same guarantees however the
analysis is not quite as good and you'll
see later and then we had one more
distribution which was the our cinch
normal distribution which is you take a
Gaussian and then you apply the
hyperbolic sine functions would exactly
what to me this again provides
concentrated DP it has all of its
moments but the analysis of this like
mock and I kind of gave up on that and
we have a result but it's not really ok
so these are three new distributions I
think that's cool so the one that I want
to highlight is this box log normal
distribution this seems to be the one
that works cleanest of the things we've
tried and I think it's also very natural
because as the Sigma parameter goes to
zero you just give a Laplace
distribution
okay so I I just wanted to put in a
slide about concentrated differential
privacy since I've talked about it maybe
no all of you have seen it sort of in
one one sentence it's like a a best of
both worlds between pure differential
privacy an approximate differential
privacy you have strong composition
results and you don't have Delta which
to me is the best of both worlds of
course there's some things that are not
perfect but here there were of course
many different variants of concentrated
differential privacy and they all kind
of are getting the same underlying idea
and it's a connection to information
theory losing Raney divergences to
capture similarity of the distribution
and just to put the the definition up if
someone hasn't seen it basically an
algorithm is called has this cost rate
differential privacy guarantee if the
rainy divergence between these two
distributions on a data sets satisfies a
bound which depends on the divergence
parameters
okay so I've told you what what we're
trying to prove about it I've told you
what the distribution is so now let me
just sort of in one slide tell you how
we analyze this guy so again you take a
little placer in the variable we
multiply it by log normal I want to show
that it provides concentrated DP when
you do it with us in the sensitivity so
here's the the theorem statement
basically if you look at the
distribution of Z and compare it to Z
with both an additive and a
multiplicative distortion you're gonna
get this bound which is exactly we need
for epsilon half hips let's go
concentrate VP with this value of the
epsilon so you'll see in this this value
epsilon you have a this is the
multiplicative distortion so if you pick
larger Sigma you pay less for the
multiplicative Distortion
you said this term which is the edited
distortion you'll pay more for for that
so this the Gaussian is normal zero
Sigma square I'm sorry
yeah so it's normal 0 1 and I just
pulled out the Sigma separately and
applause can never do it with we never
changed the scale of look awesome well
what we would do is like divide it by
because you know we'll run the analysis
and we'll say ok well we have this
amount of epsilon that we want we have
this amount of okay well we could have
don't want to deal with how much we make
s and then we'll just scale it so that
we get
okay so let me try like analyzing this
in three lines so the first thing is
that the log normal deals with the
multiplicative Distortion so let's just
look at the multiplicative distortion Oh
Z versus e to the T Z we can write that
out now
rina divergence has this nice quasi
convict city property which means I can
kind of just take out the X I can say
well you know this is I'm just
multiplying both sides by X so I can
just ignore it I can divide by X and
we're done
so now we have this and then I'm just
gonna use the fact that we have the data
processing in the quality aka post
processing to just take logs so now I'm
comparing the Gaussian normal zero Sigma
squared with normal T Sigma squared and
that's something we we all know and love
it's just this here so kind of the idea
is that by putting this Gaussian into
the exponent we're just sort of adding
Gaussian noise to the multiplicative
Distortion
okay and then for the additive
distortion so we just look at Z versus
YZ sorted by s we're gonna get pure
differential privacy so and so the
intuition visible visible plots in there
as well
now Laplace is giving you something
that's gonna look like pure DP with a
scaling factor but don't worry about
that so we just get sort of a pure DP
that so scales with this s and then we
just need to combine these two together
using the triangle inequality which we
generally refer to as group privacy and
we combined them together to get exactly
this guarantee here I don't have a good
intuition for where that comes from but
it's very generic if I do the analysis
and I just say X is some distribution I
don't even tell you what X is
I'm gonna get this e to the three hours
in this way
somehow an errand
I don't know
it's not too bad if we think of Cigna as
a constant it's a constant or there's
some optimization to be done
so there you can't use quasi convexity
is not enough there because you'd have
to take like the maximum over right so
that's the first thing I tried to use
like exactly this approach except now I
take the Y out but then I have like
something that has a log normal here
that was the intuition that so yeah so
the initial intuition was that we sort
of take this thing do the other way
around
take it out get rid of the Y just do
with the X and then okay so the analysis
of the uniform log normal turns out to
be quite similar to this the same the
same trick here works you also get pure
DP but the constants are a little bit
worse and it's a little bit Messier we
then we applied the triangular quality
so the other distribution I showed you
was the opposite normal distribution the
analysis of this is completely different
rock and I filled up several boards
trying to try to figure out what's going
on and it's not very good we do have a
result there
so we conjecture that you can analyze
that much more nicely okay so one more
thing I want to want to mention is that
we need to look at the tails of these
distributions so all these distributions
that I've mentioned to you have tails
that are quasi polynomial so that means
if I look at the probability that my
noise exceeds some threshold Z that's
going to be something like e to the
minus log of Z squared now we can't get
an analogous bound on the moment so the
thief moment of the distribution is
going to be something like e to the P
squared so this this is necessary and
it's pretty easy to show you to prove a
lower bound this is gonna be three lines
so let's apply group privacy so we know
that Z the distribution of Z is about
the same if I add a yes but again I can
do a distortion by a multiplicative e to
the t I do another distortion all the
way up to KT and I have some sort of
group privacy saying that this
distribution is close to this
distribution so now I can relate the
probability that Z exceeds this what's
the probability that Z exceeds this here
and if I pick my parameters right that's
just gonna be something like Z greater
than zero which half and so now that's
the parameter I have to say it in there
to the Kay to make that work and we use
some sort of group privacy bound on the
divergences so this is just the KL
divergence this is gonna be at most half
K squared epsilon squared that's
privacy bound following these
inequalities through and use rearrange
that you write out what this divergence
is and you'll get a sign that's like P
times 1 minus P is greater than e to the
minus K squared well simple find that
that's P is greater than equal minus log
Z squared which is exactly what we're
okay there's a lower bound that shows
that this is tires no way to avoid these
equalities
you just wanted chaos so this is we're
still applying group privacy here right
so root privacy blows up the alpha
parameter so you can know at the end I'm
gonna gonna use KL I'm gonna have to go
up to alpha equals K
okay great so this is the exponential
blow though this is depending on the
definition of the smooth sensitivity
requiring the G function to be satisfied
is near the T thing and is it possible
but there's an alternative way to look
at these local modulite of continuity
where we don't require this kind of
exponential behavior that is a really
great question and I wondered about it I
don't see an alternate but you could
imagine multiplicative changes like sort
of have changes in snow I don't know it
seems like a thing to play with them try
see the worse okay so that's me telling
you about the basics of sensitivity in
some algorithms so let me apply that to
the trimming so I'll just remind you of
the theorem that I I promise you I've
proven I'm gonna do that so again we're
gonna have a contrary DP algorithm and
that has this mean squared error it's
the optimal error plus something that's
much lower will return some some logs
so again this matches the previous work
by Salil and vishesh and it extends to
unknown Sigma so you just have to add
this extra term that is like a ratio the
upper bound you have on Sigma to the
lower bound you have months ago and it
does not specific to Gaussian data the
only thing that I'm using in the proof
is that it's symmetric and you have a
good tail bound nice tails if you have
like heavier tail this log might become
like a lot of square root of its Laplace
was like that okay so here's the
algorithm this is just the generic
smooth sensitive the algorithm we have
the function f that's the true mean now
I need to pick and I've told you about
which noise distribution Z we're going
to use so what I need to tell you about
is how do we pick this smooth upper
bound on the local sensitive
so let's analyze the mean squared error
of this guy that's a factor very nicely
so the mean squared error of this
algorithm is the mean squared error of
the F which is the true mean plus the
variance of the noise are adding times
the expected smooth upper bound G
okay so that's the non-private thing we
can analyze that that has optimal thing
a little bit from a little bit of loss
from the trimming and the noise of the
scale of the the noise is going to be
something like one of the amps along all
the remains is to pick this function G
and then prove a upper upper bound on
this six validation
okay so reminding you what the the true
mean is again and I've already mentioned
we have a local sensitivity down on this
I want a smooth sensitivity bound and
the optimal smooth sensitivity bound is
is this function here so we take the
maximum of all databases local
sensitivity at that database times e to
the minus T times the number of points
they have to change to get to that and
sit down and work that out it has this
expression which is tractable to work
with basically the idea is you can only
move move these things to basically to
the next guy or a couple of steps along
by changing one day to one so and this
turns out to have a n log n time
algorithm shoot
and just a little technical thing so we
have to define what happens when you ask
for like X minus one that's just going
to be the bounds a and that's why you're
gonna get beat okay so that's the the
function G now let's analyze the
expectation of G squared so this there's
a we can so look at all these N squared
terms and just pick out two upper
bounding terms that we want so we look
at the X and minus x1 so it's a maximum
X minus the minimum X and then we have
this additional term which is kind of B
minus B and a the the worst-case bounds
but we're not gonna see that until it's
been down weighted by T so if things are
Gaussian we can easily bound this this
is just tale a Union bounce we get Sigma
squared times login and then we're gonna
save the parameter and so that this term
here basically disappears term and we'll
say the the T smoothness parameter P
some I guess long so just set some
parameters taking Union bound now we get
some bounds on the on this expectation
of sensitivity squared
now just plug that in and that's how we
get the the result
okay so the end you're trimming about
one of Reps long points off each end
yeah
or we're trimming about this condition
up here is just saying we have some
where does the extra money it's the
maximum that's like the Union bound
accent cinnamon so I don't know what
Sigma is I just know that Sigma is
between reach Sigma min and Sigma max
then I
so the point is just there's lots of
terms and here and we'll just like pick
two terms that upper bound button the
first bone is for any dataset because
you're considering privacy so you should
hold for any knee bring and I just need
to bring it coming from the gumption so
I'm just trying to figure out where
you're plugging in the Goshen oh so yeah
so this expectations for the baby
this works for always yeah there's no
there's no randomness and this one the
random is great give a nice and do you
think the login term is necessary for
for if you hope on this slide is it so
if you're planning to only trim off like
less than n then like you're not gonna
win at more than a constant factor by
looking at but if you are playing to
chop off like a constant fraction so
well the time I take into infinity then
you're gonna do but then you'll pay for
it in the variance of the trimming right
so there's a trade off if you take off
too much that Ramin costs you if you
take off
less than you would have to have this
I don't know which is the like
putting this way to write the result
but did you try it like optimizing
burden like if you trim more it would
reduce this term to ten so this I mean
this sitting parameters needs to be
optimal for the galaxy at least you
could imagine that you have like a high
distribution I guess empirically you
could use the top chrétien rather than
we're just using this upper bound right
something we do use this empirically and
do you know how this from my graphs
okay great so this is the theorem that
we proved yeah as Adam was getting it
there were lots of trade offs here so we
could divide this log and but then this
term will become larger
squared matters so there's this
trade-offs here Josie and data I think
this is the right thing that the
question is if you have different
distribution
okay great so it goes into the talk I
want to just sort of show you some
graphs so I did some basic experiments
there's nothing nothing fancy yeah so
let me this is a let me give you so
here's a bunch of different noise
distributions that I've talked about so
this is the normal uniform log normal
students T with three degrees of freedom
which is the variance this is just the
trimming with no noise and this is what
happened as if you just use global
sensitivity which would useless and here
I put 200 data points and assuming some
sort of bound on the range of 5,250 its
standard Gaussian noise one and what I'm
plotting here is the excess variance
that you get relative to just the
non-private optimal thing which would be
1 so this line 10 to the 0 that means
you have a hundred percent more variance
or twice the variance you would have
every privately as you see what we're
getting under that line
and you know down here the stage the
minus one they would be like 10% more
variance so the kind of annoying thing
about sort of writing up the comparison
like an experimental comparison between
these they won't satisfy different
privacy definitions so I'm not entirely
sure what the right apples to apples
comparison is so some of these are
concentrated differential privacy and
this one is pure differential privacy
and of course the question is what
happens if you want to compare to the
other things like approximate
differential privacy so I also have that
graph so this is the same thing but not
added in Laplace which is gonna satisfy
one ten to the minus six differential
privacy and I've added in Gaussian which
will satisfy a different version of
concentrated be people truncated
concentrated DP so the the black one is
the truncated CDP so this is doing
pretty well now you can see that the
Laplace lognormal is the best curve
other than this non private one the
students T is pretty close behind so
that was that huge improvement but the
uniform log normal I met that really
sucks you know obviously we need to
improve that analysis and then we'll
applause with epsilon Delta V P that
seems to be doing really poorly and
maybe there's some more squeezing the
analysis to make that bitter but it does
seem that deltas if you need to pay for
a long one of the Delta that really does
hurt you you're not getting any using a
thin tail distribution
looking at variants right right yeah so
variance is probably not the right
comparison point if I want to highlight
the fact that is it your your vertical
axis is the variance it's the variance
times n minus one which is like
subtracting off the variance initially I
didn't have this minus one but then
everything just like collapse this is
this for N equals 200 I have plots like
up to like n equal to thousand and then
so this is N equals five hundredths so
everything else is exactly the same I
just have larger end oh yeah oh I
haven't said well both the horizontal
axis is Liz the amount you're trimming
so over here you're just getting the
mean of it here's the median so that the
the data is a little noisy because I
only ran these experiments this morning
and I didn't have at some point I'll
have less noisy plots so you've seen
this some some trade up so over here the
sensitivity is high so you're adding a
lot of noise for privacy even though the
the true mean is doing very well and
over here you're probably losing more
from the true mean
variants plus also I guess the smooth
sensitivity also stops going out at some
point so there's a sweet spot in the
middle so the same equals 500 this is N
equals a thousand so see that these
things are getting kind of squished
together so what we're seeing is that
you're indeed the NAM like the trimming
is what's dominating it and then I think
one final plot which is instead of
varying the trimming fraction I very n
so here's I see what all of these things
are down which is the right direction
others yeah for like N equals a thousand
we're getting pretty reasonable results
maybe these Epsilon's are a little too
large but I think these plots are
encouraging
okay so just just wrapping up so since
it is great I hope I've convinced you of
that how many offers if you're one too
three okay they're all here so so yes um
yeah the contribution here is that I we
have some new distributions that you can
use with smooth sensitivity they seem to
be pretty cool they have all their
moments which is and I think the
application gaseume estimation is so in
terms of further work obviously chopper
upper and lower bounds or for this
specific problem I think you know the
analysis I showed you it does not look
very tight it would be kind of nice to
get the maybe the constants of the
something nice here obviously moving to
arbitrary distributions rather than just
gaussians there we have some results in
that direction everything does seem to
some generalize fairly well but we might
say the right results there and of
course other applications of smooth
sensitivity I think this is a idea that
needs to find more uses because it is
it's cool and it's underappreciated so
sort of other things that you look at is
like scale estimation so or if you also
want to know what Sigma is can you give
you there and I have some ideas for how
to do that confidence intervals is what
the sheesh was talking about on Monday
and of course more complicated things
like regression or model fitting
philippe's should also be able to
framework and of course you know we
could have asked for other noise
distributions or better analyses of the
ones that I have in particular the
uniform walk normally if you ever should
have houses that's it
[Applause]
when I did
there is back-of-the-envelope
calculations one time ago it seemed that
in these types of said The Situation's
is smooth sensitivity scaling with
Epsilon
it was like not that great so it'd be
something like 1 over epsilon squared
and as epsilon got really small I'm
trying to remember there's something
trade-off right because as epsilon
shrinks you're smoothing more until you
pay for that right and I was just
wondering if you look if you kind of
duck into that yes so one of the one of
the things that I kind of liked about
these distributions is that there's a
sigma promoter that i can like you can
make it larger and as a trade-off with
the smoothing parameter and the epsilon
and it you said you said signaling for
the so for the plots i numerically
optimized signal
small SAT or other problems of your
paying exponentially
in terms of the defenders of sunlight
about do you have on the Sigma 4 CDP at
least I think so but I don't have a
lower bound so the you think like we
have to resort to sort of PQR
actually sorry
[Applause]